this horrible terrorist leader is no
more
in an address to the nation from the
roosevelt room of the white house u.s
president joe biden spoke about the
operation he ordered that killed the
isil leader abu ibrahim al-hashemi
al-qarashi
and i directed the department of defense
to take every precaution possible to
minimize civilian casualties
knowing that this terrorist had chosen
to surround himself with families
including children we made a choice to
pursue a special forces raid at a much
greater risk than our to our own people
rather than targeting him with an
airstrike as u.s special forces moved in
the isil leader reportedly detonated an
explosive in a final act of desperate
cowardness he chose to blow himself up
taking several members of his family
with him the mission happened thursday
in northwestern syria in idlib province
residents on the ground said at least 13
people including children were killed in
the operation the pentagon said there
were no troop casualties
mr president biden his vice president
and national security advisers oversaw
the mission from the situation room of
the white house it was the biggest u.s
raid in syria since the 2019 operation
that killed isil leader abu bakr
al-baghdadi this operation was literally
months
in the planning the u.s targeted the
isil leader for threats he allegedly
posed to u.s interests and crimes
committed in iraq in 2014 including the
enslavement of yazidi women the raid
comes a week after the defense secretary
ordered the u.s military to do more to
protect civilians in combat operations
often largely forgotten in the west for
syrians maybe the only
silver lining of this is it has brought
back media's attention to the conflict
in syria it seems from their perspective
that no one really cares
so one advantage in a sense is that this
has now brought syria back into into the
news despite efforts to limit casualties
some members of congress are now calling
for an investigation into the civilian
deaths to ensure that every reasonable
step was taken to protect innocent lives
kimberly hellcat al jazeera the white
house